we spend the next 10 days having from
the Australian living it up we were in
love again we will not cut the kids
giggling and we were just so happy no
responsibilities no worries no money
problems we had more money than we could
possibly spent in two weeks he just did
whatever we fancied like that actually I
want to go from where how much if you
dollars no worries
excuse me we just went out on a limb
restaurants every every meal English
breakfast yeah I mean there that is I
think one of life's little luxuries you
can pay for breakfast you know you don't
have to worry about housework cooking
washing up that was brilliant
original house laying by the pool
getting drunk in the middle of the day
let's have another beer let's get drunk
it's only two o'clock in the afternoon
but who cares
we're out we're doing it we enjoy
ourselves in the Sun in Australia
nothing could go wrong nothing peaceful
so we got to the end of the holiday
Keef said to us that the night before we
were gonna leave and get on the plane
somebody would come to the hotel and
they would drop off what it was that he
wanted us to bring back we had no name
he didn't tell us what time he was going
to turn up he just said make sure you're
in all that evening
yeah they'll be I'm saying but we got
Telus update RPG service there's no way
you're brave it was around about ten
o'clock at night I was quite late
there's a knock on the door and we're
both thinking is this room service is
this the guy and I wish the door I said
it and I was just fairly sort of Pataki
dressed all right and he just he just
said yeah that was I'm standing there
with this bag so this is what we've been
waiting for this is the time where we
thought right what is it that we're
dealing with and there was a book or a
magazine or something just on the top of
the bag I went to the bed and just
upended the bag
oh my god we counted it and their
bundles of ten thousand I think 250,000
Australian dollars in cash so most money
I've ever seen in my life
hell us a lot of money and we
were desperately worried about where he
caused this money from it looks very
much like it's drug money how can this
be legal Glenn isn't initially I said
well if there's anything that's remotely
dodgy I'm gonna put it in my suitcase
because I don't when you get into
trouble I know it's your brother but
I'll take it whatever it is but it
wouldn't all fit there's no way I could
get that much money in my suitcase and
not make it obvious you know there had
to be stuff around it so ended up having
to use both the suitcases it's too late
to back out now we're leaving tomorrow
we're gonna get on the plane and we're
gonna go to Hong Kong we've got to do it